if you hello my name is Doreen ani I'm a
designer from Tanzania my labels Curtis
cattle girl and I mostly to multimedia
production at multi the company called
nurofen distributes i'm here today to
ask a question from elaine horses and
she has please tell us what you care
about what future direction we seek and
how you will contribute to put in the
state of the world ok to answer the
first part of the question what I care
about I care about all i care about
freedom of expression i care about
education I come from a country where
I'm no majority of the you know children
are not privileged to get good quality
of education I'm very passionate about
girls and I really like to you know do
something to get as many girls and boys
educated you know I would like to I've
started a movement called what's your
freedom and basically what you're
feeling is a movement about you know
encouraging people to express themselves
and to nurture the things that give them
full satisfaction I think if we
encourage our children from a very young
age to pursue the things they love and
to nurture their their talents you never
know what opportunities my present
themselves in the near future um how
like how would I contributes well I a
class that right now but what future
there are two doors like I would like to
be combined internationalize designer
and I would also like to become a
director and I know producer and
whatever it is that I do with in this
line of work in the industry I'm going
to try and make sure that it's always
going to be meaningful and send a
message across especially to do with
education and a massive facing women
because that's what I'm very passionate
about yes